contre le virus c'est une course de fond
qui s'engagent et nous n'en sommes qu'au
début nous ne savons pas encore pour
combien de temps nous devrons nous tenir
à distance les uns des autres mais une
chose est certaine il faudra se montrer
très patient et très solidaires
une autre chose est certaine il ne faut
pas avoir peur de le dire
dans un premier temps les premiers jours
la situation va continuer à s'aggraver
avant que les effets du confinement de
la prise de distance fassent leurs
preuves
je rappelle que ces effets permettent de
limiter le nombre de personnes infectées
et le nombre de personnes admises dans
nos hôpitaux
la france est loin d'être isolé dans sa
stratégie le confinement généraliser la
fermeture des écoles
la limitation des rassemblements sont
des mesures désormais adopté par la
quasi totalité des pays européens
nous ne faisons ni plus ni moins que les
autres et nous nous inscrivons dans une
stratégie concertée au jour le jour
seuls les moments de mise en place ont
pu être différent tenant compte des
différences de stades d'épidémie
constaté dans chacun des pays
les français s'interrogent les français
nous interroge légitimement sur
l'étendue actuelle du confinement et
notre capacité à le faire respecter
ils s'interrogent et nous interroge sur
la durée de ce confinement
j'ai saisi le conseil scientifique de
ces questions légitimes
il rendra des conclusions lundi notre
ennemi est récent il était d'ailleurs
encore inconnu au début de l'année 2020
et grâce à la recherche grâce à la
science grâce à la médecine
nous le comprenons mieux chaque jour
plus personne désormais ne sous-estiment
la dangerosité du virus
pour l'homme je rappelle que si 85% des
symptômes sont bénins que 98 à 99 % des
gens qui souffrent de l'infection
guérisse le coc vide 19 peut tuer si les
personnes les plus fragiles sont aussi
les plus âgés et les plus malades
il y a dans nos services hospitaliers
dans nos services de réanimation de
nombreux patients plus jeunes et
jusqu'ici en meilleure santé
le confinement généralisée appliquée
partout avec rigueur avec détermination
c'est la clé la clé pour vaincre
l'épidémie
la clé pour donner du temps à nos
soignants à nos hôpitaux
la clé pour sauver de nombreuses vies et
je veux vous le dire comme je le pense
en de pareilles circonstances la
désinvolture la légèreté ne sont
malheureusement pas seulement
irresponsable
elles sont dangereuses dangereuse pour
soi est dangereuse pour les autres
depuis le premier jour les français ont
pu observer avec fierté mais aussi
soulagement que nous étions capables
d'une union nationale indispensable pour
maintenir la cohésion dans notre société
je le redis la polémique non plus n'a
pas sa place à l'heure d'un péril inédit
et au vu des sacrifices consentis ces
derniers jours un enjeu est sur toutes
les lèvres celui des équipements en
masques de protection
je veux dire aux français en particulier
aux soignants que je comprends et
partage leurs attentes et parfois leur
colère face à cette situation qui de
fait prive un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens de masques dans des
situations qui le nécessitent pourtant
vous savez face à une épidémie d'une
telle ampleur il pourrait être
facile de mobiliser notre énergie sur la
recherche de responsabilités
je nous invite pourtant collectivement à
mobiliser dans la période
notre énergie auprès de celles et ceux
qui sauvent des vies avec celles et ceux
qui maintiennent notre pays en vie il
sera temps au moment voulu de tirer
toutes les conséquences en matière de
préparation de notre pays face à une
menace qui je le rappelle constitue une
première sanitaires depuis plus d'un
siècle dans notre pays ayant dit cela je
veux me livrer aujourd'hui comme je lé
fais à chaque occasion depuis que je
suis ministre
un exercice de transparence absolue et
vous présenter la situation telle
qu'elle est
suite à de premières alertes sérieuses
qui aurait pu évoluer comme la crise
actuelle les pouvoirs publics ont pris
la décision il ya une dizaine d'années
d'équipé la france d'un milliard de
masques chirurgicaux de 600 millions de
masques ffp2 souvenons nous qu'à
l'époque certains avaient raillé la
ministre de la santé de l'époque pour
toutes ces précautions les vérités
d'hier ne sont pas celles d'aujourd'hui
quelles que soient les processus de
décisions ayant conduit à ce que ces
stocks ne soit pas renouvelée dans la
durée toujours est il que ces stocks de
masques se sont réduits année après
année de sorte que lorsque le qu'ovide
19 est apparu il ne restait qu'un stock
d'état de 117 millions de masques
chirurgicaux pour adultes et aucun stock
stratégique d'état en masques ffp2
c'est parce que nous avons dès le début
considérer que la disponibilité en masse
qu allait être une difficulté dans la
gestion de cette crise qu'il a été
décidé de recourir dès le mois de
janvier à l'importation de masques en
provenance de tous les pays producteurs
avant même les premiers cas sur notre
territoire national nous avons tout mis
en oeuvre pour augmenter notre site
dans un marché vous le savez extrêmement
tendu où une grande partie de la
production vient de chine
berceau d'épidémie la france en plus des
stocks et de la production nationale
renforcée a ainsi passé plusieurs
commandes de masques de protection à
l'étranger auprès d'industriels en
capacité de fournir rapidement de gros
volumes ainsi je peux vous annoncer que
nous avons d'ores et déjà signé
plusieurs commandes pour plus de 250
millions de masques qui sont livrés
progressivement et le seront au cours
des prochaines semaines
en parallèle de nombreuses personnes
institutions entreprises se sont
mobilisés face à cette situation
exceptionnelle pour faire don de masques
supplémentaires
le crédit agricole lvmh tbc je tiens à
les remercier de leur engagement
exceptionnel pour protéger notre système
de santé et nos patients les plus
fragiles
j'entends bien sur l'urgence de donner
des masques à ce qui nous protège à ceux
qui nous soignent à ceux qui sont
malades
ma responsabilité de ministre c'est
aussi de tout mettre en oeuvre pour que
ces masques si indispensable puisse être
délivré dans la durée je connais la
durée de nos stocks
je ne connais pas encore celle de
l'épidémie c'est pourquoi une stratégie
nationale d'utilisation des masques a
été mise en place afin de pouvoir
préserver notre système de santé nos
soignants et les patients les plus
fragiles
elle nous permet de garantir que toutes
les personnes qui doivent être protégée
par un masque puissent en bénéficier
pendant toute la durée de l'épidémie je
veux revenir brièvement sur les
décisions déjà prises avant d'annoncer
celle à venir
les masques ont d'abord été distribués
au sein des zones de circulation active
du virus parce que notre choix a
toujours été de donner la priorité aux
personnels exposés et aux zones qu'ils
en avaient le plus besoin
à la fin du mois de février 15 millions
de masques chirurgicaux ont été livrés
aux établissements de santé de première
et de deuxième ligne dès le 3 mars à la
demande du président de la république
nous avons sécurisé notre équipement
masques par une réquisition de toutes
les ressources disponibles sur le
territoire national nous sommes le seul
pays à avoir pris une telle décision dès
le début du mois de mars également nous
avons distribué 25 millions de masques
pour répondre aux besoins des
établissements de santé de référence
mais aussi aux professionnels de santé
de ville professionnels du secteur
médico social et transporteurs
sanitaires des livraisons de masques ont
aussi été réalisés ces 17 et 18 mars à
hauteur de 1,6 million de masques ffp2
et de 10,7 millions de masques
chirurgicaux pour les professionnels de
la médecine de ville
les infirmiers libéraux notamment en
première ligne pour la prise en charge
en ville de malades suspects ou
confirmés de kobe 19 vous l'aurez
compris j'ai fait un choix difficile
mais un choix responsable celui
d'octroyer les masques de protection
d'abord aux professionnels de santé pour
nous permettre de tenir le plus
longtemps possible
depuis des semaines nous travaillons
jour et nuit à augmenter la production
et les importations de masquer toute
production possible a été commandée
toute production disponibles a été
réquisitionnée toute distribution
possible a été assurée un
approvisionnement a été réalisé ces
tout derniers jours auprès des
établissements les plus exposés dans le
grand est
dans les hauts de france en occitanie en
ile de france et en bourgogne franche
comté un approvisionnement global
destiné aux établissements de santé à
tous les établissements médico sociaux
ainsi qu'aux transporteurs sanitaires a
été réalisée à l'échelle nationale hier
encore un nouvel approvisionnement sera
effectué dans les jours qui viennent
pour consolider les stocks
le total de ces deux livraisons
représentera 10 7 millions de masques au
total depuis la dernière semaine de
février
70 millions de masques ont ainsi été
livrés aux professionnels de santé de
ville à l'hôpital et dans nos ehpad
grâce à l'acquisition des stocks et de
la production sur le territoire national
grâce aux dons grâce aux importations
nous avons récupéré dans le même temps
depuis cette dernière semaine de février
près de 40 millions de masques
supplémentaires
nous disposons à ce jour d'un stock
d'état de 86 millions de masques 5
millions de masques aux normes ffp2 81
millions de masques chirurgicaux
à titre de comparaison nous prévoyons
une consommation de 24 millions de
masques par semaine dans notre pays
voilà la réalité des chiffres la réalité
c'est aussi que ces derniers jours la
logistique a été très complexe à gérer
et nous avons pris du temps pour assurer
la meilleure répartition possible jeudi
prix et non perdu parce qu'encore une
fois dans les zones les plus sensibles
nous avions et nous avons des stockés
des masques pour faire face à cette
urgence inédite que nous traversons nous
avons donc réarmer notre système de
production et de logistique de façon
colossale et rapide la mise en place
d'une chaîne de distribution adaptée a
effectivement été complexe je le sais
mais elle fonctionne maintenant et elle
permettra d'approvisionner
pis tu mens les hôpitaux les praticiens
en ville les pharmacies les acteurs du
soin à domicile
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
et des patients pour qui l'utilisation
des masques est recommandée j'en profite
pour remercier du fond du coeur des
pharmaciens d'officine qui depuis le
premier jour se mobilisent dans des
conditions que je c'est difficile la
transparence toujours la france est
désormais en mesure de fabriquer six
millions de masques supplémentaires
chaque semaine pour moitié des masques
ffp2 dès le mois d'avril
ce seront 8 millions de masques par
semaine les producteurs français ont mis
leur chaîne de production en tension ces
chaînes fonctionnent pour répondre à une
demande sans précédent
toutes les usines tournent à plein
régime deux nouvelles chaînes de
livraison ont été mises en place en
urgence pour assurer la distribution de
masques à l'ensemble des professionnels
de santé prenant en charge ou étant en
contact potentiel avec des patients
atteints de corona virus enfin comme
nous l'avons déjà indiqué le président
de la république et le premier ministre
ont demandé au ministère de l'économie
au ministère de la défense d'identifier
toutes les alternatives potentielles
soit pour démultiplier les chaînes de
production soit pour qualifier des
alternatives jetables ou réutilisables
les ministères ont qualifié des bancs de
tests mis à disposition des industriels
des spécifications et 40 prototypes sont
en cours de test pour des masques
chirurgicaux
comme pour des masques ffp2 je salue la
mobilisation des industriels sur ce
sujet qui doit nous permettre d'apporter
des solutions notamment vers les
secteurs autres que celui de la santé de
nombreuses alternatives innovantes sont
en cours d'expertisé pour répondre à ces
besoins urgents de protection les
industriels français sont pleinement
mobilisés
avec les pouvoirs publics pour répondre
à cette urgence sanitaire et je tiens à
les en remercier
elle montre la créativité la solidarité
dans l'adversité de nos entreprises et
de nos concitoyens dans les prochaines
heures
d'autres initiatives seront prises pour
augmenter massivement les importations
de masques en provenance des pays
producteurs ainsi que pour orienter
toute l'industrie disponibles dans notre
pays toute l'industrie disponibles dans
notre pays vers la production des
matériels de protection à destination de
celles et ceux qui doivent en bénéficier
au regard de ses capacités de production
et au regard des stocks disponibles
nos priorités restent les suivantes
d'abord protéger les professionnels de
santé
amené à prendre en charge des patients
coville 19 en ville comme à l'hôpital
préserver les capacités hospitalières de
prise en charge en protégeant les
personnes qui interviennent auprès des
personnes âgées en ehpad pour éviter les
hospitalisations
ce sont là des priorités absolues
protéger les soignants c'est protéger
les malades et c'est en définitive
sauver des vies entre ceux qui
souhaitent être rassuré ceux qui doivent
être protégés j'assume de donner la
priorité aux seconds la distribution de
ces masques est en cours comme je viens
de vous l'indiquer et nous travaillons
sans relâche à optimiser leur
distribution partout où des
dysfonctionnements ont pu intervenir
l'inquiétude légitime de la population
face à cette situation inédite entraîne
également des comportements dont je
voudrais que je voudrais condamné avec
la plus grande fermeté
nous avons effectivement constaté de
nombreux vols d'utilisation des tournées
inadaptée des masques de protection
que ce soit à l'intérieur des hôpitaux
en cours de distribution
jusque dans les véhicules de certains
soignants fracturé pour leur voler le
caducée en espérant aller obtenir des
masques et les revendre ces
comportements je le dis met en danger
nos soignants et diminue les
disponibilités de masques
soyons responsables ensemble protégeons
ce qui nous soignent j'entends la
demande de matériel de protection de la
part de plusieurs professions pouvant
être au contact direct avec la
population et mardi à la demande du
président de la république nous
recevrons le conseil scientifique pour
envisager toute modification toute
extension des modes de répartition des
masques au delà des seuls soignants et
personnes malades
cette réflexion devra bien sûr intégrer
la contrainte que je viens de vous
détailler s'agissant du stock de masques
et intégrera au fur et à mesure que les
commandes arriveront pour renforcer
notre stock national issu de la
production française et des importations
cela viendra enrichir notre réflexion
mais je le dis les masques limite votre
transmission du virus
si vous pouviez le porter en permanence
mais certainement pas votre exposition
car votre exposition elle elle est
constante
les masques protège certains mais seuls
les gestes barrière nous protège tous
car il ya transmission par les mains et
les objets si vous ne vous l'avez pas
les mains très régulièrement
l'immense majorité des transmissions
n'est pas interdite et par le masque
elle est arrêtée par la prise de
distance par le lavage des mains par les
gestes barrière prenons un exemple très
concret en population générale
une personne qui marche dans la rue pour
aller faire ses courses elle n'a pas
besoin de porter un masque parce que le
virus se transmet essentiellement par
les mains et il faut rester plus de 15
minutes à moins d'un mètre d'une
personne contagieuse pour que le risque
de transmission par la bouche se
développe
c'est pourquoi j'invite toute personne
qui dispose encore de masques
à les remettre à la disposition des
soignants en les déposant à
l'établissement de santé le plus proche
à un médecin un infirmier libéral ou
dans une pharmacie d'officine
j'invite toute entreprise toute
organisation qui en disposent à se
rapprocher de l' agence régionale de
santé la plus proche ou pour les stocks
les plus importants et il y en a on
parle là de phoques de plus de 200 mille
masques à se rapprocher directement de
mon ministère
ces masques ils doivent revenir
prioritairement à ceux qui en ont
vraiment besoin et je vous assure que
les gens en réanimation portent des
masques
toute la journée j'en viens au choix que
nous avons fait pour la distribution de
masques dans les quinze jours à venir et
qui découlent
à chaque fois de doctrine validées
scientifiquement
nous donnerons comme nous l'avons fait
jusqu'à présent la priorité à la
protection des professionnels de santé
amené à prendre en charge des patients
coville 19 en ville comme à l'hôpital et
nous donnerons également priorité à la
protection des personnes qui
interviennent auprès des personnes âgées
en ehpad pour préserver les capacités
hospitalières pour la prochaine
distribution nous procéderons donc de la
façon suivante pour les médecins de
ville
pour les biologistes médicaux les
infirmiers de ville
nous allons distribuer 18 masques par
semaine et par professionnels dont des
masques ffp2 dans le strict respect des
indications pour les pharmaciens de
ville 18 masques chirurgicaux par
semaine et par professionnelle pour les
masseurs kinésithérapeutes si masques
par semaine et par professionnels
chirurgicaux ou ffp2 dans le strict
respect des
indications et selon les disponibilités
pour la réalisation des actes
prioritaires et nombreux portables pour
les sages-femmes si masques chirurgicaux
par semaine pour la prise en charge des
femmes confirmé coville 19 pour les
chirurgiens dentistes
ces professionnels disposent désormais
d'un stock délier de masques qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes répartie et je les en remercie
sur le territoire de façon à pouvoir
dans la durée assurer les soins urgents
à la population pour les prestataires de
services et les distributeurs de
matériel une boîte de 50 masques
chirurgicaux par semaine et en moyenne
par entreprise pour assurer les visites
prioritaire pour les personnes exerçant
des activités de services d'aidé et de
soins à domicile 9 masques chirurgicaux
par semaine et par professionnels
exerçant au sein de la structure pour
assurer les visites prioritaire ces
personnes pourront s'approvisionner en
masques auprès des officines dans les
territoires les plus touchés
je veux saluer chaleureusement ces
professionnels et leurs encadrants c'est
grâce à eux que nous pourrons organiser
une prise en charge à domicile et des
retours d'hospitalisation dans de bonnes
conditions pour les ehpad et pour les
structures médico-sociales accueillant
des personnes fragiles notamment les
personnes en situation de handicap ou
les patients coville 19 sans domicile ne
relevant pas d'une hospitalisation
nous distribuerons cinq masques
chirurgicaux par lies ou place et par
semaine s'agissant encore des ehpad
je sais qu'il y a eu des tensions dans
certains endroits
j'ai reçu hier une lettre rendue
publique signée de responsables des
fédérations des ehpad me demandant de
leurs 40
dire qu'il disposerait de 500 mille
masques chirurgicaux par jour compte
tenu des fragilité extrême des personnes
âgées qui résident
je leur réponds ce jour que j'ai entendu
leur demande et qu'ils disposeront dans
la durée de ces cinq cent mille masques
chirurgicaux par jour nous sommes avec
les professionnels pour les aider à
s'organiser à se protéger et à protéger
les résidents pour eux ainsi que pour
les autres établissements médico sociaux
qui prennent en charge des personnes
particulièrement vulnérables
les masques seront disponibles dans des
établissements plateforme le nombre de
masques sera proportionnel à la taille
des établissements
lorsque des symptômes apparaissent la
dotation devra permettre de couvrir en
priorité les personnes qui oeuvrent
auprès des cas possibles ou confirmés à
tous les professionnels des ehpad
je veux dire un immense merci vous êtes
les gardiens des plus fragiles d'entre
nous j'en viens aux établissements de
santé pour les pour l'hospitalisation
conventionnel nous distribuerons trois
masques chirurgicaux par jour et pas
professionnel de santé dans les services
de soins prenant en charge les cas
possibles ou confirmés et pour la
réalisation des gestes à risque bien sûr
des masques ffp2 dans les services
d'urgence les services d'accueil des
malades qu'ovide 19 et de soins
critiques et de réanimation pour
l'hospitalisation à domicile
nous distribuerons deux boîtes de 50
masques chirurgicaux par semaine et en
moyenne par structure pour les
transporteurs sanitaires et les centres
de secours
nous distribuerons une boîte de 50
masques par semaine et par structure
pardonnez moi pour cette liste longue je
vais souhaiter exhaustive
transparente de manière à répondre à
chacun des acteurs qui sauvent des vies
au quotidien et qui prennent soin de
nous je veux aussi profiter de mon
intervention pour vous parler d'un autre
sujet qui anime et c'est normal les
citoyens la question des tests
diagnostiques là aussi j'entends on est
question les attentes
l'incompréhension parfois comme
j'entends l'expression publique de
nombreux experts dans le même esprit que
celui qui a présidé à la distribution
des masques
nous avons fait jusque là le choix d'un
usage rationnel raisonnable raisonnée
des tests rationnelle car il ya une
logique qui prévaut lors de chaque
épidémie
quand un virus circule vite ne pas
dépister de manière systématique mais
base et de suivi sur la surveillance des
symptômes
c'est ce que nous faisons chaque hiver
lorsque nous gérons par exemple
l'épidémie de grippe raisonnée car
réaliser les tests mobilise
d'importantes ressources qu'il s'agisse
de la mobilisation des professionnels
pour prélever ou des réactifs pour les
réaliser les tests ne servent pas à
mesurer mais à contenir l'épidémie
en la matière je rappelle que nous
sommes depuis le premier jour
parfaitement alignés sur les
recommandations et pratiques
internationales au stade 1 au stade 2
nous avons testé l'ensemble des cas
contact des personnes malades
ce qui nous a par exemple permis un
contrôle remarquable souvenez-vous du
foyer de contamines montjoie en haute
savoie
j'avais même souhaité aller plus loin en
procédant au dépistage systématique chez
tous malades hospitalisés en réanimation
ou soins intensifs avec des troubles
respiratoires sévères
aujourd'hui nous ne détestons pas de
façon automatique
car nous avons fait un choix comme la
plupart des pays et conformément aux
recommandations
la commission européenne de réserver les
tests à des publics prioritaires les
personnes ciblées sont comme chez nos
voisins européens
les personnes les plus à risques et les
professionnels de santé symptomatique
les personnes âgées symptomatique les
personnes qui présentent des difficultés
respiratoires sévères ou d'éco mobilité
c'est-à-dire des fragilités des maladies
chroniques les personnes hospitalisées
et tout nouveau foyer ou nouveaux
territoires jusqu'ici épargnée par
l'épidémie en france nous avons aussi
fait le choix complémentaire de
prioriser les femmes enceintes les
donneurs d'organes les donneurs de
cellules les donneurs de tissu
chaque jour ce sont plus de 4000 tests
qui sont effectués sur ces personnes
nous avons atteint un total supérieur à
60 mille tests réalisés dans notre pays
actuellement 70 laboratoire en plus des
50 déjà équipés sont en capacité de
réaliser des tests
nous sommes ainsi parmi les premiers
pays européens en matière de capacité de
dépistage et nous souhaitons monter en
puissance
la capacité journalière de réalisation
des tests va ainsi continuer d'augmenter
ce n'est pas là une simple hypothèse de
travail c'est un impératif de santé
publique
la doctrine d'usagé rationnelle et
raisonnée des tests doivent évoluer
lundi dernier le docteur tedros
président de l'organisme directeur
général de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a délivré ce message simple tester
tester tester la france doit donc
désormais suivre cette voie et se
préparer à faire évoluer rapidement sa
stratégie de dépistage
l'enjeu c'est d'être en mesure de
multiplier nos capacités de test
au moment où nous lèverons
confinement c'est l'enjeu au moment où
nous le voulons confinement au moment où
nous permettons à chacune et chacun de
reprendre le cours normal de sa vie
nous devrons pouvoir vérifier que les
personnes pour lesquelles il y avait un
doute présenter ou non la maladie qui
quand je dis multiplier cela veut dire
multiplier pas juste augmenter sans
attendre nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des industriels en france
comme à l'étranger pour augmenter ses
capacités de test dans les plus brefs
délais l'espoir je le dis est aussi
tournée vers la recherche qui pourrait
nous permettre d'ici à quelques semaines
je dis bien pourrait nous permettre
d'ici à quelques semaines ne disposait
d'une nouvelle méthode diagnostique plus
simple plus rapide plus largement
diffusé à bhl sur tout le territoire
national
vous l'avez compris ce n'est pas sur la
base d'un dépistage massif que nous
mettrons fin au confinement
mais c'est sur la base un dépistage
massif que nous pourrions être amenés à
accroître notre surveillance
une fois le confinement levées
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans les
prochains jours kara situation évolutive
vous l'avez compris stratégies
évolutives mardi je verrai avec le
président de la république le conseil
scientifique à nouveau cette fois ci
pour évoquer cette question des tests
diagnostics ainsi qu'une autre question
qui préoccupe les français et qui me
préoccupe tout autant la question des
traitements
ma stratégie vous l'aurez compris l
éclair adapter rapidement nos décisions
en fonction de l'évolution des
connaissances et des recommandations
pour toujours mieux protéger les
français c'est ce que je fais également
en matière de stratégies thérapeutiques
en m'assurant au jour le jour que si
demain un traitement démontré son
efficacité
les français puissent en disposer sans
délai que nous ne manquions ni de stock
de médicaments ni de capacité à produire
des médicaments pour répondre à la
demande
ni même des matières premières
indispensable pour y arriver j'ai depuis
le premier jour de ma prise de fonction
encourager accompagner faciliter toutes
les études de recherche clinique visant
à répondre à la demande des chercheurs
et à l'heure à laquelle je vous parle
plusieurs sont en cours dans des grands
hôpitaux français mais ministre de la
santé jette aussi le j'ai aussi le
devoir de respecter l'exigence
scientifique et sanitaires avant toute
décision de traitement
j'ai aussi le devoir et l'exigence de
tout faire pour que nous puissions le
plus rapidement possible trouver des
traitements et des vaccins mesdames et
messieurs mon souci de la transparence
reste comme au premier jour
total la voici avec des chiffres et des
annonces on ne peut plus clair nous
avons une méthode et nous la suivons
pour permettre à notre système de santé
de tenir bon pour permettre de protéger
ceux qui en ont besoin
dès que la situation se présente
permettez moi pour terminer de saluer et
de dire la reconnaissance de la nation
toute entière aux soignants qui en
première ligne lutte avec un courage
exceptionnel je salue aussi et je
remercie chaleureusement celles et ceux
qui assurent le ravitaillement et la
distribution des biens essentiels
je remercie les services de l'état je
remercie nos forces de police et de
gendarmerie et toutes celles et ceux qui
permettent à la france de se protéger et
de tenir bon votre soutien quel que soit
votre façon de l'exprimer en
applaudissant à vos fenêtres à 20 heures
comme vous le faites spontanément en
apportant à manger aux soignants en
rendant votre véhicule disponible pour
ramener une infirmière
chez elle après une longue nuit de garde
ou tout simplement
en garantissant par votre travail la
continuité de la vie économique de notre
pays
votre soutien est magnifique quel que
soit le poste de travail que vous
occupez sachez qu'il constitue forcément
un maillon essentiel de la chaîne qui
relie économie et santé sans frigo pas
de médicaments sans composants
électriques pas de frigo sans matières
premières pas de composants électriques
sans transport de marchandises pas de
matière première à l'arrière du front le
rôle de chacun est crucial parce que
nous sommes dans une guerre de positions
en respectant les consignes qui vous ont
été données vous permettrez aux
soignants d'agir plus vite vous
permettrait de réduire la propagation du
virus vous permettrait à la france de
faire face à cette épidémie
nous vivons un moment historique c'est
une épreuve sans précédent que nous
devons surmonter aujourd'hui ensemble
je compte sur chacun d'entre vous
poursuivre avec rigueur les consignes
qui vous sont donnés mais aussi pour ne
pas céder aux sirènes de la polémique et
le et de la division la situation est
bien trop grave
soyons solidaires soyons courageux
soyons à la hauteur du défi qui se
dresse devant nous je vous remercie
bonjour monsieur le ministre on jours
cécile la ronce en ce 3 pour france
télévisions je vais être le porte-parole
de tous mes confrères aujourd'hui
puisque je suis la seule journaliste
aujourd'hui présente avec vous dans
cette salle de conférence de presse et
j'espère être fidèles par rapport à
rester fidèles par rapport à toutes les
questions qu'ils ont posées elles sont
nombreuses
première question en fait je vais poser
la première question à mon nom donc pour
france 3 vous parler de sacrifice de
confinement qui sort à la clé qui est la
clé pour vaincre l'épidémie
pourquoi ne pas miser plutôt sur un
dépistage massif comme l'ont fait les
coréens du sud et au vu de leurs
résultats on pourrait s'en inspirer
pourquoi ne pas être misé sur ce
dépistage massif et rendre un peu de
liberté aux français merci je ne pose
pas la question il avait dit tout à
l'heure la question du dépistage avec la
question du confinement
un dépistage n'empêche pas la
propagation du virus un dépistage
n'empêche pas la transmission du virus
et un dépistage n'empêche pas une
épidémie ça peut être une méthode la
corée et le tas pays qui s'illustre par
la capacité qu'elle avait mis en place
historiquement à réaliser des tests
massif à très grande échelle
la corée est un pays qui a payé un très
lourd tribut aux précédentes forme grave
de grippe ou souvenez h1n1 la grippe
aviaire et la corée avait donc un
dispositif qui lui était propre et qui
est absolument d'ailleurs unique au
monde la france j'entends souvent dire
que la france est en retard par rapport
aux tests etc
j'ai dit que la france réalisé
aujourd'hui 5000 thèse que la france a
toujours collé aux recommandations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé elle
fera toujours cette stratégie
puisqu'elle elle entend l'appel du
directeur général que je viens de
relayer en disant que nous allions
monter notre capacité de test mais
lorsque vous avez une épidémie qui est
présente sur le territoire national
lorsque l'épidémie est une réalité
et lorsque l'épidémie a diffusé sur le
sur tout le territoire
le confinement est la seule possibilité
de freiner les choses comprenez-moi bien
le testing systématique
il était encore possible raisonnable il
il a d'ailleurs été fait dans l'oise il
a été fait aux contamines montjoie
il a permis d'enrayer l'épidémie et de
supprimer la circulation du virus ce qui
s'est passé notamment à mulhouse avec
une diffusion et une transmission dans
plusieurs secteurs de la france a rendu
inopérante toute velléité de protée de
procéder à un testing massive quand bien
même les moyens techniques auraient déjà
été mis à disposition
j'entends encore une fois la remarque et
la corée n'est pas la france mais si
vous regardez par exemple aux etats-unis
nous avons nous avons déjà réalisé je
crois 30 ou 40 fois plus de tests que
les américains eux-mêmes qui dispose
pourtant de moyens technologiques pour
le faire alors pour magali closer du
moniteur des pharmacies les pharmaciens
ne reçoivent pas la totalité des masses
qui doivent leur parvenir une pharmacie
proche de colmar n'a reçu qu'une boîte
de ffp2 pourquoi je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure nous avons distribué 1,7 million
de masques ffp2 10,4 à 10,6 millions de
masques chirurgicaux répartis sur les
quelques 20 mille pharmacies d'officine
du territoire si vous faites la division
ça fait beaucoup
12 millions et demi de masques mais si
vous leur apportez au nombre de
pharmacies ça fait un nombre modéré de
masques par pharmacie et si vous leur
portez au nombre de professionnels de
santé qui doivent bénéficier des masques
cela fait dénombre encore plus petit
donc il ya les pharmacies qui ont reçu
des stocks plus importants parce qu'ils
correspondent à un territoire de santé
où il ya plus de professionnels de santé
et puis certaines pharmacies ont été
livrés en deux temps ont reçu lundi et
mardi dernier et des masques
chirurgicaux et n'ont reçu que vendredi
les masques ffp2 je vous ai parlé des
difficultés logistiques
je ne vous ai même je vous épargne les
détails sur les droits de retrait de
certains de certains
raison sur certaines disparitions sur
les difficultés aussi inhérentes au fait
que quand on a fait une réquisition de
masques et bien aller chercher des
masques pour les amener à bon port peut
être un peu plus compliqué mais je vous
assure que le problème est désormais
réglé et que les livraisons vont se
faire en bonne et due forme en temps et
en heure alors une question d'aurélie
francs pour un pm news est-ce que vous
avez des infos plus précises sur les
décès et le nombre de cas dans les ehpad
est ce que vous confirmez dans le 12e
arrondissement un ehpad de la fondation
rothschild avec 48 cas dont et 6 décès
je vous confirme que nous surveillons de
très près la situation dans les ehpad où
les personnes sont très fragiles sont
déjà très fragile et où l'infection par
le cos vide peut avoir des conséquences
encore plus dramatiques qu'ailleurs il y
a effectivement alors je je ne parlais
pas de la situation particulière de cet
ehpad pardonnez-moi le territoire est
vaste
nous avons plusieurs milliers de malades
et de foyers il y aura tout à l'heure un
communiqué de presse qui rendra compte
de la situation sanitaire du jour en
lieu et place de la conférence de presse
habituelle puisque c'est moi qui me
présente devant vous aujourd'hui
vous aurez sans doute toutes ces
informations mais sachez que les
situations dans les ehpad sont des
situations que nous regardons de très
très compte tenu de la fragilité des
personnes âgées raison pour laquelle
j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure que les
ehpad bénéficierait de 500 mille masques
chirurgicaux par jour
alors nicolas evra le généraliste des
épidémiologistes et chefs d'état indique
que 60 à 70 % des personnes seront
touchées par le colis est ce que cela
signifie que l'épidémie continue at on
une idée du taux de personnes touchées
en france à ce jour
alors on considère effectivement que
pour qu'un virus
arrête de circuler il faut qu'il y ait
une certaine proportion de la population
qui soit immunisée l'immuniser il ya
deux façons de lettres où vous avez été
infectés ou vous avez été vaccin
mais comme nous n'avons pas de
vaccination dans le cas du cos du coc
vide 19 mai que les chercheurs du monde
entier ne travaillent qu'à cela
désormais c'est par la voix de
l'infection que les gens peuvent être
immunisé savoir quel est le pourcentage
de population qui doit être immunisé
pour que la circulation de ce virus en
particulier s'arrête et très complexe
puisqu'il n'y a aucune démonstration qui
en a été faite dans aucun pays
il y a beaucoup de modélisation beaucoup
de prévisions qui nous viennent des
scientifiques français anglais italien
chinois coréens
nous avons un institut de santé publique
qui se chargent de compiler toutes ces
données et de nous faire des objectifs
prévisionnels et d'être capable de
modéliser les choses pour pouvoir
toujours anticiper je ne peux pas vous
donner un chiffre
ce serait vous mentir mais les experts
sont dans leur rôle en faisant des
propositions ou en postulant qu'une
certaine partie de la population sera
touchée ce qui est essentiel aujourd'hui
c'est de freiner cette épidémie pour
donner du temps aux hôpitaux
limiter la circulation du virus quant à
savoir combien de français sont
aujourd'hui infectés par le coronavirus
vous avez trois données je vous les
expliquent très brièvement
vous avez le nombre de patients que nous
annonçons chaque jour qui correspond au
nombre de patients testés positifs
c'est plus de 12000 patience ma mémoire
est bonne hier vous avez le nombre de
patients qui peut être rapportée au taux
attendu de mortalité de 1% et qui fait
qu on pourrait estimer qu'il y aurait
plus de 30 à 40 mille malades en réalité
en france et vous avez d'autres façons
de calculer ou d'estimer le nombre de
malades vous savez qu'il ya presque une
personne sur deux qui est malade et qui
ne s'en rendra jamais compte qu'on
appelle des porteurs sains et donc ça
pourrait monter jusqu'à 80 ou 90 mille
malades donc la fourchette pardon pour
l'expression mais du nombre de malades
en france probable varie entre 30 et 90
personne alors julie clézio
l'observatoire de la santé
avez vous une idée de la date du pic de
l'épidémie en france il est très dur de
savoir la date du pic de l'épidémie
puisque nous n'avons pas suffisamment de
données sur la contagiosité sur la durée
de contagion et surtout je vais vous
dire une chose
ce qui m'intéresse c'est moins la date
du pic épidémique
ce qui m'intéresse c'est comment est-ce
qu'on est collectivement capable de
faire en sorte que ce pic soit le plus
tardif et le plus modéré possible vous
souvenez de ces courbes avec le pic
épidémique si on ne fait rien et le pic
épidémique si on arrive collectivement à
agir pour que se confiner et limiter la
circulation du virus c'est cela la donne
et qui est la plus importante
gaël guéï et du loup du concours médical
que pensez vous des résultats de l'étude
du professeur raoul sur des effets
thérapeutiques spectaculaire de la
chloroquine je connais bien le
professeur out j'ai eu encore hier au
téléphone et je lui ai toujours donner
les moyens de mener ces protocoles
thérapeutiques clinique dans des délais
record 24 heures la dernière fois pour
qu'il puisse conduire son étude je
m'entretiens régulièrement avec le
professeur out ainsi qu'avec l'ensemble
de la communauté médicale et
scientifique qui fait de la recherche
sur des traitements
j'ai permis et même demandé à ce que
l'étude du professeur out puisse être
reproduite à plus large échelle dans
d'autres centres hospitaliers par
d'autres équipes indépendantes
je suis sa d'extrêmement près
aujourd'hui je n'ai aucune donnée
suffisamment validées scientifiquement
médicalement pour tendre vers une
recommandation mais j'ai donné toutes
les impulsions nécessaires pour que nous
ayons ces données s'il devait être
positive ou négative dans une période
que j'estime à moins de 15 jours
auquel cas si les résultats étaient
positifs nous pourrions aller vers une
voie thérapeutique si l inverse les
résultats n'étaient pas reproduit c'est
à dire s'il était décevant
eh bien nous aurions essayé pourtant le
professeur à autun a obtenu de bons
résultats apparemment
mardi dernier il a obtenu des résultats
sur 24 malades sans placebo avec une
étude ouverte je vais pas vous faire
tous les résumés et et protocoles
thérapeutiques mais jamais aucun pays au
monde n'a accordé une autorisation de
traitement sur la base d'une étude comme
celle ci dont encore une fois
j'accueille et je reçois les résultats
du professeur out je reçois aussi
l'énergie qu'il met et de la façon qu'il
a de se battre et de convaincre
l'ensemble de la cadence des soignants
pour pouvoir expérimenter ce traitement
et je serai le plus heureux des
ministres si je pouvais vous annoncer
demain que nous avons un traitement qui
a fait montre de son efficacité que je
peux vous dire c'est que tout est prêt
si jamais ça devait être le cas mais
encore une fois l'histoire des maladies
infectieuses
l'histoire des maladies virales et
peuplé de fausse bonne nouvelle est
peuplé de déception et parfois de prises
de risques inconsidérées je ne serai pas
le ministre de la santé qui prendra des
risques pour ces malades mais je ne
serai pas le ministre de la santé qui
empêchera la recherche de se faire donc
je partage l'espoir de nombre de nos
concitoyens mais je suis aussi en
responsabilité obligé de dire attendons
regarde ans nous avons suffisamment
d'études scientifiques suffisamment de
données cliniques
pour béatrice jérôme le monde
pourquoi la direction générale de la
santé ne dispose t-elle pas d'un état
des lieux dans les ehpad
le ministère at il demandé un bilan bien
sûr nous avons demandé un bilan
nous travaillons avec l'organisme de
santé publique qui s'appelle santé
publique france est désormais depuis
maintenant j'ai dit désormais depuis un
certain temps nous travaillons également
en lien direct et pluriquotidiens avec
chaque établissement de santé et les
établissements santé sont aussi
organisés en j'ai acheté ce qu'on
appelle des groupements spitz et les
deux territoires qui sont capables eux
mêmes de centraliser des données est de
nous les faire remonter
nous suivons au cas par cas chaque
situation chaque activation virale et
lorsqu'il ya des foyers épidémiques
qu'ils sont observés par exemple dans
des ehpad
c'était le cas tout à l'heure j'ai été
alerté nous intervenons
immédiatement nous sensibilisons l'
agence régionale de santé pour que des
actions soient entreprises pour frédéric
haziza radio j la france aurait une
dizaine de jours de retard par rapport à
la situation italienne
les mesures de confinement décidé en
france sont elles suffisantes pour
éviter dans dix jours
autant de cas et de décès qu'en italie
faut-il aller plus loin la question du
rapport entre la france et l'italie est
une bonne question que nous suivons et
de fait nous constatons qu'il ya
effectivement un décalage de huit à dix
jours
depuis deux semaines entre la situation
italienne et la situation française
nous avons pris plus tôt que ce qu'avait
pris l'italie comme mesure les mesures
de confinement généraliser je vous le
dis la france dispose des mêmes mesures
que son voisin italien
les mêmes mesures que son voisin italien
en italie les gens continuent à
travailler tout en étant confiné en
italie les gens ont le droit à des
sorties individuel pour aller faire des
courses comme c'est le cas en france
aujourd'hui
en italie les commerçants fermaient en
france nous avons même une liste de
commerces fermés plus importante puisque
je crois que les salons de coiffure par
exemple sont restés ouverts en italie
lors même que nous les avons fermé en
france alain douillet de la fédération
nationale d'éducation pour la santé
si nous avions les stocks nécessaires
ne faudrait-il pas comme en asie
recommandé le port de masques dans tous
les actes de la vie sociale je voulais
expliquer tout à l'heure il s'est
expliqué tous les jours par le directeur
général de la santé portait un masque en
vie quotidienne déjà ça pose d'une
complexité des usages je ne dis pas ça
considérant compterait pas capable de
servir damas et pas du tout mon discours
mais qu'on ait un masque ou non on
touche au visage à peu près toutes les
minutes et on voit d'ailleurs des gens
et je suis sûr que vous en voyez autour
de vous qui porte un masque en vie
quotidienne et qui vont le réajuster ou
qui vont parfois le mettre sur le menton
je le constate des fois en regardant sur
les chaînes de télévision un masque est
une structure qui est faite de papier
qui est poreuse est en fait un masque
n'empêche pas les particules de venir
s'imprégner dans le masque le masque
empêche des barbecues
devenir dans votre bouche dans votre nez
mais si vous portez un masque qui est
imprégnée par des particules qui sont
contaminés et que vous touchez votre
masque c'est bien par les mains
qu'ensuite vous allez vous contaminer
donc l'usagé du masque en population
réelle ne correspond pas aux
recommandations internationales par
exemple de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
les soignants en revanche ont besoin du
masque parce qu'ils ont un usage
quotidien pluriquotidiens et qui sont
capables de le changer très
régulièrement et les personnes qui sont
malades ont besoin d'un masque pour
éviter d'envoyer des projections vers
d'autres personnes c'est un outil de
protection de l'autre davantage qu'un
outil de protection de soi même florence
bukiya france 2
quelles décisions pour les ehpad combien
de masques et de renforts en personnel
et quid des symptômes différents chez
les personnes âgées en ehpad diarrhée
troubles de l'équilibré confusion
mentale chez des gens qui auparavant
allée bien sûr les masques je vous ai
répondu cinq cent mille masques
chirurgicaux par jour sur le personnel
des ehpad nous sommes aussi capables
d'activer la réserve sanitaire qui s'est
enrichi de milliers de milliers de
soignants volontaire et que les agences
régionales de santé peuvent activer
territoire par territoire
lorsqu'elles en ont besoin vous
m'interrogez sur les symptômes la
question des diarrhées par exemple et
troubles digestifs
elle est connue y compris chez les
patients jeunes et quant aux troubles de
type confusion ou maux de tête vertiges
lé puisse lier d'ailleurs un état
antérieur des personnes en ehpad qui ont
souvent des démences des maladies
d'alzheimer et qui ont déjà des
fragilités et toute infection sur une
personne qui est tragique peut exacerber
ces troubles
dernière question de géraldine amiel de
bloomberg
allons nous vers un confinement plus
strict style couvre-feu est plus long et
si oui quels en seront les modalités
s'il avait des mesures territorialisée à
prendre des mesures très précises
là où on constate qu'il n'ya pas du tout
de respect des mesures de confinement là
où on constate qu'il ya une flambée
épidémique les préfets les mères parfois
sont habilités à prendre des mesures
spécifiques de type couvre-feu puisque
c'est celle que vous
je vous ai dit dans mon intervention
tout à l'heure que lundi le conseil
scientifique nous vendrait des
conclusions sur l'évaluation et
éventuellement des propositions s'il
devait y en avoir des nouvelles
quant au confinement tel qu'il est
appliqué aujourd'hui en france et la
façon éventuellement de le faire évoluer
mais je le dis nous avons atteint un
niveau de confinement généralisé de la
population qui est conforme à ce que
nous observons chez nos voisins je vous
remercie pour vos questions
m
et
monde